yolanda is with us in san diego hey
yolanda how are you
i'm i'm fine i'm very nervous but thank
you for taking my call
how can we help um this is an estate
related question um just some background
i'm in baby step
two and i've been going really hard at
my debt
but prior to me joining your program
and prior and my brother actually
before he passed away a year ago had
always
every time i saw him while he was ill
was telling me about this
land acres of land that we had in
louisiana
and he was like you can't let this land
go to waste
you have to take care of this land he
had learned
that um my grandfather's
land had oil being drilled on it of
which
oil royalties could be collected it's
also
classified as timberland and
i think it looks like it's over 40 acres
and so he passed away and it has been
put heavy on my heart to
go ahead and delve into this situation
so i've done some research
i found out that the land is and my
grandfather's
name who passed away back in 1982
and since then my father passed away in
2011
and then my brother like i said he
passed away in 2019.
are you the only survival player or were
there cousins
and nephews and nieces i so
from my research i do have one surviving
brother
my other two brothers passed away they
also
had children and my grandfather
only had two two sons my dad
and i guess my uncle i have no relation
had no relations with them
um and so right now what i did since i
really did not know how to handle this i
reached out to an estate attorney in
louisiana
who says that i need to
have a land succession
performed or done and he's going to
charge me
thirty five hundred dollars and i think
there's like
four hundred dollars of court fees do
you have any idea what the land is worth
uh that's the thing i have no idea what
the land
is worth might not be worth 3 500
well it's they are drilling oil on this
land
um so who's getting the royalty checks
well that's what i asked the attorney so
the attorney says
that in the state of louisiana that if
the oil royalty checks
are uncollected over a 10-year period
that money goes to the state that would
be true so i believe
that no one has ever collected any of
the oil
royalties for this land there may not be
any
but if they're drilling oil there
wouldn't they might be and they might
not be
i this this sounds like swampland in
florida to me
i just i just i don't i don't think you
i i think this is a pipe dream kiddo
i'm not spending 3 500 bucks on an
attorney until i get a lot more
information
i want to know what the royalty checks
are where they've been going
i want the line of succession how many
brothers sisters cousins uncles and some
people are going to be splitting into
this money
you could easily spend 3 500 and get a
net when you're done
of a thousand bucks after the property
is sold
because that oil that's out there
they're pumping natural gas out of there
and they're not getting any dead gum oil
at all
i mean this is all this is all rumor and
legend this is so funny
i'm the opposite i'm like did you hit a
jackpot i mean like how do you not know
though how do you not know that there's
just tons of oil on all these royalties
if it was a big pile of money somebody
would have already been jacked up about
it
it wouldn't have been going to the stage
tell her somebody
her brother would have been over there
camping out on the place
uh get in there and dig around if you
want kids but don't
don't drop a bunch of money on this
until you get some more information